lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es dar
una explicación acerca de la bomba sodio
potasio y como su nombre lo indica está
bombea sodio y potasio pero lo hace en
distintas direcciones este pequeño
dibujo que tengo aquí es mi
representación de la bomba sodio potasio
es un complejo proteico transmembrana y
está en estado de reposo observa que
está abierta del lado queda al interior
de la célula y tiene afinidad por los
iones de sodio que se van a pegar justo
aquí aquí los puedes ver tenemos 123
iones de sodio y estos iones se van a
unir a la bomba y justo cuando se unen
la proteína será fosforilada utilizando
una molécula de atp esta que tengo aquí
esto que dibujé es atp adenosín
trifosfato y después cuando es
fosforilada sucede una liberación de
energía que permite que cambie
la conformación de la bomba la nueva
conformación de la proteína abre hacia
afuera y está cerrada hacia adentro y
ahora deja de tener afinidad por los
iones de sodio y va a tener afinidad por
los iones de potasio y esto es
fascinante como la liberación de energía
justo aquí provoca el cambio en la
conformación de estas proteínas las
cuales son realmente maquinarias
moleculares fascinantes y bueno después
de que sucede el cambio en la
conformación los iones de sodio serán
liberados justo por aquí y se van a
liberar hacia el exterior de la célula y
ahora los iones de potasio del exterior
de la célula se unirán a la proteína
también esto durante el cambio en la
conformación de esta proteína después la
bomba será de fosforilada y volverá a su
conformación original justo lo que tengo
aquí
deja de tener afinidad por los iones de
potasio por lo que estos serán liberados
al interior de la célula y así regresa a
la fase original y esto es fascinante
todo esto se da
usando atp usando energía y justo a esto
se le conoce como el transporte activo
este tipo de transporte utiliza energía
para mover los iones de adentro hacia
afuera y de afuera hacia adentro déjame
notar lo que estoy hablando del
transporte trans
x
te activo
ti
con este tipo de transporte al usar el
atp somos capaces de bombear 3 millones
123 3 iones de sodio hacia fuera de la
célula déjame escribirlo
estoy bombeando hacia fuera de la célula
3 iones de sodio de sodio y en el
proceso también se transportan 122 iones
de potasio son los que van a entrar así
que lo voy a poner aquí dos iones de
portas yo van a entrar y seguramente me
vas a decir que esto hace que el
exterior de la célula sea más positivo
que adentro de la célula y aunque esto
es cierto no es lo único que provoca la
diferencia de potencial entre el
interior y el exterior de la célula lo
que realmente provoca esta diferencia de
potencial es que en la membrana
plasmática también hay canales proteicos
en que los iones de potasio se difundan
a favor de su gradiente de concentración
pero pensemos con calma todo lo que
acabo de decir lo que quiero preguntarme
es cuál es el gradiente de concentración
del sodio
esto claro debido a la bomba sodio
potasio bueno primeramente observa que
hay una mayor concentración en el
exterior que en el interior y entonces
este va a ser el gradiente de
concentración del sodio
aquí tengo una mayor concentración mayor
aquí una menor concentración menor y
entonces este va a ser el gradiente de
concentración del sodio y cuál es el
gradiente de concentración del potasio
bueno pues observa que el potasio es lo
contrario al suyo hay una mayor
concentración desde ión adentro de la
célula que afuera de la célula y por lo
tanto el gradiente de concentración va a
ir en sentido contrario aquí tengo una
por concentración y aquí tengo una menor
concentración ahora si dejamos que el
potasio salga de la célula y de hecho
hablamos de estos vídeos pasados
recuerdas de cómo la membrana no
facilita el paso de varias moléculas y
que no es muy permeable a cosas como los
iones de potasio o de sodio pero si hay
canales proteicos como éste que permiten
que el potasio salga entonces qué pasará
y bueno puedes pensar en dos ideas
distintas
la primera puedes deducir que debido a
que hay mayor concentración de los iones
adentro de la célula que afuera de ella
entonces la probabilidad de que los
iones se muevan en esta dirección hacia
el exterior va a ser mayor que la
probabilidad de que los iones se muevan
hacia el interior por lo tanto hay un
flujo neto de potasio hacia el exterior
celular y puedes decir ok esto tiene
sentido si solo te fijas en el gradiente
de concentración pero
la segunda idea es qué pasará si vemos
las cargas porque estamos diciendo que
el interior de la célula es menos
positivo que el exterior aquí tenemos el
interior de la célula es menos positivo
menos positivo por sí
que el exterior el cual es más positivo
más
sí
y esto es a la diferencia que se debe a
un flujo neto de iones hacia fuera justo
por la bomba de sodio potasio y bueno
los iones de potasio no van a querer
estar con los iones de su misma carga
está de acuerdo se querrá mover a un
lugar más negativo entonces porque
querrán esos guiones de potasio con
carga positiva ir de un lugar menos
positivo a un lugar más positivo y bueno
ya sea que tengas la idea del gradiente
de concentración o la idea de la
diferencia de potencial eléctrico
estarás en lo correcto en ambos casos
estas son fuerzas que están en
equilibrio en primer lugar el gradiente
de concentración permitirá que uno de
estos iones de potasio salgan de la
célula pero ojo la concentración de
adentro y de afuera nunca podrán ser
iguales debido a la diferencia del
potencial eléctrico porque aquí aquí
afuera es más positivo que aquí adentro
cuando salen van
contra de lo que la carga quiere que
hagan pero eso sí van a favor de su
gradiente de concentración pero en un
punto llegarán a un equilibrio y bueno
al examinar este proceso vemos que al
bombear el sodio hacia fuera en mayor
proporción de lo que se bombea el
potasio hacia adentro se permite que se
hagan más cargas positivas y por lo
tanto se establece lo que se conoce como
el potencial de membrana en reposo de la
célula y esto es súper importante para
todas las células pero en especial para
las neuronas estas células gastan dos
tercios de su energía sólo para
establecer o mantener su potencial de
membrana en reposo y esto es como
veremos en futuros vídeos sobre neuronas
que se deben a que ellas aprovechan este
potencial para mandar señales a otras
neuronas su potencial de membrana en
reposo es menos positivo aquí adentro
es positivo aquí afuera entonces si tú
me das esto adentro
utilizando como referencia lo que tienes
afuera vas a encontrar una cierta
diferencia y esta diferencia dependiendo
de la célula que estudies es cercana a
menos 70 menos 70 micro volts bueno en
algunas células puedes encontrar valores
de menos 60 o menos 80 pero en promedio
esa es la diferencia de potencial y es
clave para las neuronas pero también
para todas las células ahora la bomba
sodio potasio no solo se dedica a
establecer el potencial de membrana en
reposo está alta concentración de sodio
que tenemos acá afuera de la célula
también se puede utilizar para otras
formas de transporte activo cuando se
mueven a favor de su gradiente de
concentración puedes tener cosas como el
transporte de moléculas de glucosa y
otro tipo de transportes que veremos más
adelante y bueno no me canso de decirte
que los sistemas biológicos
bastante complicados y en varios vídeos
te digo esto porque quiero darle el
crédito a este proceso para que sepas la
importancia de esta bomba fue
descubierta en 1950 pero en 1997 dieron
el premio nobel por el descubrimiento de
la bomba sodio potasio y de cómo
funciona